you know a lot of times when you as a
scientist think back to experiments that
you've done even really successful
experiments you realize that at the time
that you were doing you didn't really
fully understand the science involved
over the science behind that what
science was gonna affect whether you're
gonna get results or not and you
probably also didn't really appreciate
how lucky you were I would I said I
would rather talk a little bit about one
experiment that a wonderful experiment
that I was did many years ago with
Christian a new sign full heart with at
the time when we were both starting out
our our scientific careers we like many
people the time this is the late 1970s
were interested in problem of embryonic
development but at a very basic level we
knew that genes controlled things that
you could see happening in the embryos
and we wanted to identify what the who
those genes were what they did and there
were a lot of different molecular
strategies conceptual strategies that
you could use to do this we decided that
we would try a genetic approach and what
that meant for us was that to build on
you know certain things to build on our
lack of knowledge and to just randomly
mutagenize all genes knock them all out
and see what happens and get some
estimate at least or some global picture
of what it was the genes were doing
during development how gene activities
were organized in in patterns and in
sequences to produce the extraordinary
phenomena that you see in in development
we knew that there were lots of genes
and we knew that understanding the
process would probably require that we
identify most of them so we we had we
set up in our minds at least a this goal
that we wanted to identify everything we
wanted to identify all the genes and
this meant a really big experiment and
for those of you
who have any sense or experience with
working with Drosophila what a big
experiment and looking for lots of genes
means is lots of tubes growing lots of
flies and setting up crosses basically
our plan was to feed flies mutagens take
established inbred lines from single
males and the first generation then
carry it through an appropriate number
of generations to produce inbred
homozygous lines that we collect
homozygous inbred heterozygous signs
that we can collect homozygous embryos
from and we thought about it and our
estimates of what we need to do is
something like in the range of maybe
40,000 lines established through many
generations and for us to do that
we realized and this is actually the
first real secret and the unappreciated
aspect of this experiment is that we
were starting our jobs in in Heidelberg
and we knew that we had to set up lots
of tubes we would identify all these
genes and if that was going to be
effective we would have to have ways of
I'm also mechanized been reading of
flies we couldn't sit and set up crosses
manually by hand we would have to
selective procedures that allowed us to
manually collect individual it would
avoid collecting individual flies
instead of process we're actually the
first two years of our stay in
Heidelberg was involved in this good a
setting up and designing genetic crosses
that allowed us simply to put a fly in
the tube wait two weeks there'd be lots
of flies in there for two flies in the
tube actually wait a couple of weeks and
a wait next generation and by raising it
at a different temperature with some
other selected technique we could just
shake the flies out the surviving flies
over and go through and gradually in
breed the line such that at the end of
the cross down here at the bottom after
three generations we had balanced inbred
lines that we could collect homozygous
embryos for now it took us two years to
set that up and to get crossing schemes
that would actually work
we set out to do the experiment and the
experiment actually itself only took us
over two rounds of experiments each of
which were less than two months in
advance so I guess the first lesson the
idea that if you have a vision and the
vision is clear enough you may still
have to spend a lot of work just getting
you know a lot of it's the work just
getting the assays getting the
procedures right but then the next thing
this is thing that I really wanted to
talk about next and the next number
actually and we were we did actually
start out with trying to make 40,000
lines well as you'll see we only really
carried about 27,000 of them through to
the third generation but by the time we
gotten to that generation began to get
our first results we got it a important
first important really result that we'd
used enough mutagenesis that in the
lines that we were looking at we had
about and these 27,000 lines we had
about 18,000 different mutations and so
that meant that our mutagenesis
procedures were work everything was
working fine our interest though these
mutations kill the fight at any time
during the during its life cycle and
when we were really interested in what
genes that control the way embryos
developed and this is the point actually
where I think we were extraordinarily
lucky because what we had to do was now
from all these 18,000 eight of these
different lines we had to collect mutant
embryos we had to collect embryos look
at the embryos that died and decide
whether the gene that was mutated in
those lines actually killed the embryos
and killed him in an interesting way and
the great result thing that we couldn't
have anticipated was that of the 18,000
different lethal mutations only a tiny
tiny fraction actually changed
homozygous embryos in a way that was
really meaningful and we most of the
time the homozygous mutant embryos
hatched and crawled away it didn't have
to be that way and what would have been
really really horrible for us and
thinking back to it is that if every one
of those 18,000 lines we picked out
looked at embryos and there was some
phenotype something
wrong we would never have actually been
able to I think since there was really
only the two of us doing these
experiments sort things out and come up
with a coherent picture so we were
really lucky that what had actually
happened was that in a way that we
didn't fully anticipate The Scream was
it's very selective selective for
mutations that cause phenotypes in
homozygous embryos that is to say we
were selecting four genes that had to
themselves be transcriptionally active
in embryos and that in flies that number
is very small and so the number of
mutations was about 586 and actually the
number of genes because if you do
complementation test among those
mutations are only about we'll only
found a hundred thirty-nine different
genes so that's a really small number
and that reduced the problem for
thinking about development down to one
hundred and thirty nine components
hundred and thirty-nine genes each of
which were producing different
phenotypes and could be arranged in
pathways and sequences that made for me
at least the whole process of
development almost understandable or
structural for the first time that
understanding came from the fact that
the numbers are small the final numbers
as well and the numbers are small not
because we planned them that way
the numbers are small because of the
peculiar biological features of the way
you know the way flies developed and
said flies develop memory unavailable is
very rapid the mother puts everything
the embryo needs now that she can
possibly put into the egg is put in by
the mother and the transcriptional
requirements it's certainly early during
all these patterning stages are very
minimal so the fly has stripped down its
transcription or requirements to the
rare genes that must be can't be
supplied by the mother that must be
supplied by transcription in this cell
and not in this cell is genes the
embryos using transcription to control
patterns to control transitions in time
so we did an experiment a genetic
experiment that was oriented towards
identifying homozygous
phenotypes in homozygous
embryos and because of the biology flies
the way they worked
we ended up identifying the central set
of core regulatory genes whose
activities temporally and spatially
control the development of pattern and I
think if I think back to what both Jana
and I at the time we thought a lot about
this experiment we as I said we planned
it for two - more than two years we
actually spent two years trying to get
the things set up and yet we didn't
really fully understand how the system
worked how fly embryos develop or what
until we actually had the numbers and
had the results and yes I actually a
great lesson in min biology and then the
one hand you don't understand the
experiment really that you're doing
until you get the result and it's really
only when you get the results you
actually understand that it's actually
potentially understand what biology and
what the whole the whole system that you
work with is actually giving you that's
true and and and so I think we it is
though pretty much I guess the nature of
science it's really great to do
experiments where you don't know the
outcome
you